في المقابل قال مكتب الناطق الرسمي باسم
قوات الدعم السريع ان بعض وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تناقلت ما سماها مزاعم بان قوات
الدعم السريع قامت باعمال حربيه تجاه مطار
مروي واوضح المكتب في بياننا قوات الدعم
السريع هي قوه قوميه تعمل في اطار القانون
بتنسيق وتناغم تام مع قياده القوات
المسلحه وبقيه القوات النظاميه الاخرى
واضافت ان وجودها بالولايه الشماليه وفي
مدينه مروي ياتي ضمن وجودها في بقيه
الولايات في اطار تاديه مهامها وواجباتها
التي تمتد حتى الصحراء وادعت قوه الدعم
السريع جميع المواطنين ووسائل الاعلام الى
عدم الانسياق وراء ما وصفتها بالمعلومات
الكاذبه التي تهدف الى اشاعه الفتنه
وتقويد امن واستقرار الوطن بحسب البيان